it was a remarkable moment an FBI raid
on the home of a former U.S president
Donald Trump revealed the search at his
Mar-A-Lago property earlier this month
on social media it provoked outrage
among supporters now the Department of
Justice has released the affidavit used
to secure a search warrant signed off by
a judge Trump and his team had already
handed over 15 boxes of documents he
took with them when he left the White
House they should have gone to the
National Archives going through the
boxes investigators found highly
sensitive documents in the 30 AP Jaffa
defit which is highly censored the FBI
laid out its case for a further search
claiming they believed there were more
sensitive documents at Mar-A-Lago which
could injure the us if they fell into
the wrong hands that despite assurances
from Trump's legal Team all documents
had been handed over
that these sensitive documents were
being improperly handled
and that the material possessed could
mean three possible crimes were being
committed it's pretty hard to make out a
case that this is a Witch Hunt when it
has these kind of elements to it that
the entire United States is being
endangered by this kind of recklessness
and I do believe that he definitely is
in criminal jeopard reacting on his
truth social Channel Donald Trump said
affidavit heavily redacted nothing
mentioned on nuclear a total public
relations subterfuge by the FBI and doj
or are close working relationship
regarding document turnover we gave them
much in the White House briefing room
there was a determination to keep the
current president out of the political
fight we feel that it is not appropriate
for us to comment on this this is an
independent investigation that the
Department of Justice is leading that's
something that the president finds uh is
an important thing to do for the
Department of Justice to have that
Independence we're just not going to
comment
but he did just a few minutes later
dismissing the former president's claim
he Declassified all the documents well I
just want to know I've Declassified
everything in the world I'm president I
can do it all come on
I'm not going to comment because I don't
know the detail I don't even want to
know I'll let the justice department
take care
it's unusual for such an affidavit to be
released before charges are lead if
charges are to follow that will be a
discussion at the highest levels of the
Department of Justice in the days to
come Alan Fisher Al Jazeera Washington